تابعنا خلال هذا الفيديو المصور والفيديو
الذي قبله بعض مشاهد الدمار والقتل التي
يخلفها القصف الذي يشنه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على بعض المناطق مخيم النصيرات
بوسط قطاع غزه وكذلك في خان يونس في الحي
الياباني اطلعنا اكثر على تفاصيل هذه
الصوره محمود هو هذا واقع الحال وهذه
الصور تكاد تكون تتكرر في كل غاره مع كل
غاره تشنها هذه الطائرات الحربيه تدمر
المنازل تحوله الى تحول هذه المنازل الى
كومات من الركام وبالتالي ينجم عن ذلك
اعداد من الشهداء اعداد من الجرحى
بالتاكيد مفقودون تحت هذه هذا الركام
ودائما هذا الامر يخلق صورا من هذا النوع
ويخلق معه عقبات كبيره امام رجال الاسعاف
امام الناس الذين رعون الى المكان وامام
طواقم الدفاع المدني التي تحاول دائما
تركيز جهودها فيما يتعلق بانتشال ناجين او
محاصرين اذا ما كانوا تحت هذا الركام
وايضا انتشال الجثامين والبحث عنهم جثامين
الشهداء هذا الامر ربما شاهدناه في
الفيديوهات التي عرضت قبل قليل كانت هذه
الغاره في الحي الياباني الى الشمال
الغربي من مدينه خانيونس هذا الامر ادى
الى تدمير المنزل واستشهاد ثلاثه من
المواطنين اصابه اخرين وصلوا الى هذا
المستشفى وهناك اعداد اخرى ما تزال مفقوده
حسب المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه يجري عمليه
بحث عمليه تحري في محاوله لايجاد هؤلاء
المفقودين وبالتالي هذه العمليه تكررت قبل
ذلك في منطقه خانيونس ايضا باستهداف منزل
اخر في قلب مدينه خان يونس الامر الذي ادى
الى استشهاد خمسه من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين واصابه اخرين والمعلومات
تتحدث عن وجود مفقودين باعداد كبيره ربما
باعتبار ان هذا المنزل كان بداخله اعدادا
كبيره من المواطنين والنازحين ساعه
استهدافه بطبيعه الحال من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه اليوم كان التركيز
كما يبدو من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في غاراتها على المنطقه
الوسطى من قطاع غزه وبالتالي وزعت ها
وتوزعت هذه الغارات على مناطق النصيرات
ودير البلح والزوايده وفي الشرق من هذه
المحافظه المغازي والبريج بحيث ان هذه
الطائرات استهدفت في كل محافظه منزل واحد
على الاقل الامر الذي ادى الى سقوط اعداد
كبيره من الشهداء والجرحى وما تزال هناك
اعداد من المفقودين حقيقه تحت ركام هذه
المنازل منذ يوم امس هناك تركيز واضح على
هذه المحافظه بالتاكيد الى جانب ما يجري
في خانيونس ومنطقه غزه والشمال ولكن هناك
ربما رفع لمنسوب
ووتيرة فعي هذا هو ما يجري محمود على
الارض في كل المحافظات في قطاع غزه